Dave room and host the Reuben report on
YouTube and he joins us tonight so Dave
there is a very serious question here I
almost never lose patience with guests
but at certain point living in this
country you're like you know maybe
there's another explanation other than
racism sexism and Russia it's just too
limited worldview for me I can't I bore
it so what's the actual explanation why
did kammo Harris lose well Tucker let's
speak truth here right let's speak truth
the reason that Kamala Harris is out is
because she was a horrible candidate yes
she she is an authoritarian and that was
very obvious even to the progressives
who were pretty authoritarian the the
irony of everything that you've said in
the lead in here is that for all of the
people on MSNBC and CNN and all the blue
cheque Twitterati and all the lefties
and progressives who are now calling
everyone racist and sexist do they
realize this was a Democratic primary so
they're calling the Democrats racist
it's one thing that you know they
usually just call the Conservatives
racists and the Trump supporters races
and the rest of it they're actually
calling themselves racists now they're
calling themselves sexist now Kamala
there's many reasons she wasn't a good
candidate you know there's the moment
first off Tulsi really took her out yeah
in one of the debates that that was one
of the real moments and I don't think
she ever recovered from that but the
moment for me was when they were talking
about banning assault rifles as an
executive action and joe biden said the
correct answer which is that if you're
gonna do something it has to be
constitutional and she smugly smiled and
joked Oh Joe can't we just say yes we
can and it's like well no you can't we
still do have the Constitution here and
while I often wonder if the progressives
care about the Constitution at all I
think a lot of people saw that moment
and said whoa the this woman wants to do
things that have nothing to do with the
proscribed powers of the executive
branch so she was a terrible candidate
and for anyone calling the rest of the
Democrats racist and sexist right now
you might be right but you might want to
look in the mirror yeah and not not for
this I mean she was a totally shallow
person who had no idea who she was or
why she wanted to be President she was
Ted Kennedy 1980 it was a waste of all
of our times and if it
weren't for the press we would have
taken her seriously in the first place
thank you for providing that force Dave
Rubin a speaker of truth on this topic
thank you good to see you thanks Tucker
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell